Hello, and welcome one and all to Wonder Vision!
No, not that one, although we can understand
the confusion.
This is no superhero sitcom though; this is
the latest innovation from our dear friend
Doctor Wondertainment.
Tell me, have you ever wondered who would
win in a fight between, let’s say, Superman
and Goku?
Is that pairing a little too by the numbers?
Okay, how about something more like this:
Godzilla vs SCP-5514, aka The Dragonslayer,
a giant mech suit designed by the SCP Foundation
for the sole purpose of taking on giant city-destroying
creatures like the old King of the Monsters
himself.
Now, that’s more like it!
And scenarios just like that are exactly what
we’re here for!
Friends, we’ve all spent so much time pondering
the ‘what ifs’, but as much as it would
be a fun use of our time, we can’t all spend
our days daydreaming.
Luckily though, Doctor Wondertainment has
just the thing that we need; how does he do
it?
Introducing his newest and perhaps his most
ingenious creation yet: Wonder Vision.
Through the miracle of the good doctor’s
patented and highly secret technology, you
can now experience the outcomes of any fictitious
situation you can possibly think up!
And all from the comfort of your own home.
Why waste hours daydreaming, let Wonder Vision
do all the imagining so you don’t have to!
So, are you ready to take it for a spin?
Oh, of course, there are so many possibilities,
so many scenarios to think up, it can leave
you feeling a little bit spoilt for choice,
can’t it?
Tell you what, start with a fight scenario
those are always good!
An old fashioned one on one grudge match;
after all, who hasn’t wanted to see two
things that would never normally face off
with each other go toe to toe?
Here, you input the first fighter…
SCP-682, a popular choice!
The Hard to Destroy Reptile, infamously on
of the most fearsome and tenacious anomalies
ever encountered by the SCP Foundation.
Whoever you’re going to be pitting against
it definitely has their work cut out for them.
Now, you could pick out another SCP to fight
your first candidate.
But why not try something different, really
push the boat out.
After all, with Wonder Vision, anything is
possible!
So, come on, introducing your next contender…
Deadpool!
Ah, a comic book fan, are we?
Well, once again you’ve hit on an interesting
choice.
Also known as Wade Wilson, this Canadian mutant
from Marvel Comics is not only a master of
martial arts and almost every form of combat,
but much like your friend SCP-682, he’s
got a knack for healing even the worst injuries
imaginable.
This one is going to be close…
it also might take a while.
“Oh, hey there.
What is this, someone’s YouTube video?
Better watch my swears!”
So, let’s get started with your match-up!
Combatants, take your places, it’s time
for round one!
“Combatants?
Wait a minute, am I on Battleworld right now?
No wait, it’s Mojoworld right?
Okay, maybe some other ‘world’ obsessed
with one on one gladiatorial arena fights.
Is this the UFC?
Also, another question…
what the hell is that big angry-looking lizard?”
Here we go, Wonder Vision is now generating
every possible outcome.
Let’s take a look at this scenario!
Now, we all know that SCP-682 has always been
a formidable foe, and one of its attributes
that makes its so fearsome is its size.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile is an unambiguous
monster, a large quadrupedal creature sporting
two pairs of legs, a tail and a vaguely crocodilian
head, its mouth filled with razor sharp teeth.
But as the old adage goes, the bigger they
are, the harder they fall.
And nobody knows better about using an opponent’s
size to his advantage than the Merc with the
Mouth.
“You can say that again, Mr Narrator Guy!
Hey, do I really have to fight this killer
croc over here?
Oops, sorry, wrong universe.”
On top of that, good old Deadpool is one of
the most highly skilled swordsmen in the entire
Marvel Universe, rivaled only by the likes
of Wolverine, Taskmaster and Blade.
It’s a pretty well-known fact that those
dual-katanas of his aren’t just for show!
“Call it overcompensating, I dare you!”
His training and tactics already put our underdog
Wade W. Wilson at a little bit of an advantage.
But let’s not forget, SCP-682 is no slouch
either.
The reptile is known to be pretty fast when
it needs to be, fueled by its own sheer hatred
for all other forms of life.
That’s its motivation, the sole driving
force behind the creature; it thinks of anything
else as an abomination.
Whether it be a person or a plant, even other
anomalies, every living thing other than itself
are unforgivable, unnatural and disgusting
to SCP-682, and it will stop at nothing to
kill anything it sees.
Of course, that’s a little tricky when the
only person nearby is a mutant with a similar
penchant for bodily regeneration, as well
as notoriously big mouth.
As fast as the Hard to Destroy Reptile can
be, it is hindered, its own slightly larger
size can make the creature cumbersome.
It isn’t by much, but it’s just enough
for our old pal Deadpool to get to work doing
what he does best.
Unsheathing his pair of pristine swords, Wade
flies into battle as gung-ho as ever.
He lands the first blow, lodging one of his
blades in SCP-682 reptilian musculature.
The reptile lets out a furious roar, one that
would strike fear into anybody else.
But Deadpool?
Well, he’s not exactly the fearful type;
more the too insane to back down type.
Now the Hard to Destroy Reptile’s hide is
pretty thick, usually providing it with enough
protective layers to defend the creature against
most conventional forms of attack; guns, bombs,
knives or, in this case, swords.
But the adaptability and resistance of SCP-682
is only matched by Deadpool’s resourcefulness
– also his reckless and wildly unpredictable
nature.
But speaking of resourceful, his swords – sometimes
known as Bea and Arthur – aren’t forged
from any ordinary metal.
Wily old Wade Wilson has been known to wield
katana’s made out of Carbonadium, a metal
that can not only deflect powerful incoming
attacks, but the element itself is also able
to disrupt the healing factor of certain mutants,
like Wolverine.
The sharpened Carbonadium slices through the
scaly, leathery hide of SCP-682, much to the
reptile’s disgust and annoyance.
It moves to retaliate, swiping at the mutant
mercenary with its claws, each as sharp as
the blades of Deadpool’s weapons.
His natural reflexes kick in, slightly enhanced
by the process that triggered his mutation
and his rigorous special ops training.
Deadpool blocks the oncoming attack by crossing
both swords above his head, but the force
behind SCP-682’s blow staggers him.
You see, he might be slightly faster than
the life-hating lizard thanks to his smaller
size, but Deadpool simply doesn’t possess
the same muscle mass and bodily strength as
a gigantic monster.
But he can still hold his own.
“Hey, watch that cheeky double entendre
there, Mr Narrator.
God, this gecko is jacked.”
Deploying a spin manoeuvre, guiding the heavy
limb of SCP-682 over his head, Deadpool uses
his katanas like a pair of giant Carbonadium
scissors - A move that would make Able proud.
He cleaves off one of the monster’s arms,
slicing through the thick hide into the muscle
and bone beneath, causing the creature to
lose its footing, tumbling forward over itself.
Using the beast’s fall to his advantage,
Deadpool leaps onto 682’s back.
Raising his two swords, he plunges the blades
into the crocodilian head of the monster,
each one stabbing directly through its skull.
Sprays of blood, brains and viscera spew from
the wound, not that you can tell from the
state of Deadpool’s suit; that’s why he
wears red, after all.
“You joke, but do you have any idea how
hard this is gonna be to wash out?
I’m talking tide pends, seltzer water and
lemon, I swear if any of these stains set
in…”
Unfortunately, Deadpool does have a penchant
for getting distracted.
Partly fighting back out of aggression, and
possibly partly due to finding the motormouthed
mutant to be a bit of a nuisance, SCP-682
quickly rolls over onto its back.
Startled by the sudden movement, Deadpool
loses his balance and falls to the ground,
quickly followed by the full weight of a giant,
Hard to Destroy Reptile; like we said, the
bigger they are, the harder they fall.
Pinned under the beast, Wade reaches for Bea,
trying to use the sword as a makeshift crutch
to pull himself free.
“Hey, I’m down but not out!
Let me in, coach, I’ll bite his scaly ankles
off!”
Back on his two feet, and finding himself
facing an enemy back on four, Deadpool opts
for a more scorched earth approach.
It’s time for scenario two.
Few people know this about our dear friend
Mr Wilson, but he actually has more than a
few tricks up his blood-stained sleeves; or
rather, in his magic satchel.
Yes, you heard that right, the equipment bag
Deadpool is normally seen wearing has its
own extranormal properties to it.
The satchel itself contains a near infinite
pocket dimension, along with the ability to
create anything that the user needs.
Extra ammo, replacement swords, and endless
supply of stuffed unicorns…
“Hey!
How did you know about those?”
You name it and Deadpool can produce it from
his bag in a matter of seconds.
Again, we really need to get this guy and
Able to hang out sometime, don’t we?
Say what you will about the speed and ferocity
of one of the Foundation’s most notorious
anomalies, but no reptile has an abundance
of extra hardware in its pocket.
“You know, that’s not a bad idea.
I mean I’m not just doing this because you
said I would…
or who knows, maybe I am?
Hey, croc!
I hope you like pineapple!”
With that, Deadpool unleashed a volley of
grenades, all pulled from the extradimensional
satchel and launched straight at SCP-682.
The ensuing explosions are deafening, engulfing
the Hard to Destroy Reptile and the area around
it in flames and debris.
“Lucky the writers let me have my bag with
me, I honestly don’t think I’d stand a
fighting chance without it!”
Unfortunately, as we mentioned earlier, SCP-682
is pretty thick skinned, able to resist a
lot of the explosive punishment Deadpool is
dealing out.
Conventional weapons, even combustible materials
and ordinance, do little to cause the creature
any lasting harm, and mainly serve to anger
the reptile even further.
“Oh, come on, man!
What about if I use this?”
Pulling a bazooka from his magical satchel,
Deadpool launches the most destructive, expensive,
and excessive explosive he can think of: a
diamond tipped, high velocity, heat seeking
warhead.
The missile lets loose, piercing the outer
layer of SCP-682’s scales and lodges itself
deep in its side as the creature turns to
deflect the full force of the oncoming ordinance.
The reptile roars in pain and aggression to
feel the super dense tip of the projectile
burrowing into it, through its thick, defensive
exterior and into its flesh.
You might want to cover your ears for what
follows.
“Hey, stop addressing the audience, that’s
my bit!
Wait, what was that about covering ears?”
With an almighty boom, the warhead detonates,
spewing flame and chunks of charred SCP-682
in every conceivable direction.
Smoke fills the space around them, as the
monstrous creature hisses in contempt, thrashing
in pain.
Suddenly, a large, scale-covered tail whips
out of the smoke.
Still suffering from a nasty bout of military
grade tinnitus from the blast, Deadpool looks
up only too late as powerful appendage swipes
at him, sending the Merc with the Mouth reeling;
SCP-692 is far from dead.
As the fumes from the detonation clear, its
smouldering wound is already starting to heal.
But that gives Deadpool an idea.
Reaching into his magic satchel, Wade fishes
out another grenade.
The moment his gloved had grabs it, another
roar fills the area; the Hard to Destroy Reptile
begins barrelling towards the regenerating
mutant in red, baring its wide maw of sharp
teeth.
“Well, this is a terrible idea.”
Pulling out a fresh grenade, Deadpool charges
directly towards the oncoming reptile, wrenching
the pin from the handheld explosive and flicking
free the safety handle.
He leaps up into the air, aiming to achieve
a balletic flip over the head of the angry
monster.
With its tenacious and loudmouthed prey in
mid air above it, SCP-682 lifts its jaws upwards,
just as Deadpool turns to drop the primed
grenade in the Hard to Destroy Reptile’s
mouth.
This goes about as well as you’d expect;
Deadpool is caught right between the large,
crocodilian jaws of SCP-682.
The monstrous anomaly plucks the acrobatic
assassin out of the air with ease, But, in
his hand, he’s still got the grenade, and
its timer is rapidly ticking down.
Another in a series of huge, deafening explosions
rips through the head of SCP-682 before the
reptile has a chance to swallow Deadpool and
his grenade.
Thanks in equal parts to the sharp teeth tearing
him apart, as well as the blast of his own
grenade, there’s not much remaining of Deadpool
that’s still alive.
“No, I’m fine, really!
Just give me a few hours to grow back my entire
body.
Actually, could someone come and pick my head
up?
No?
That’s okay, I’ll just… roll, I guess.”
Well, technically Deadpool is still alive,
thanks to his mutation.
Much like his opponent SCP-682 here, his regenerative
healing is so effective he can continue to
function even when the rest of his body – skeleton,
nervous system, internal organs – is completely
obliterated.
Then again, just blowing off the Hard to Destroy
Reptile’s head is only enough to temporarily
slow it down, this is the same creature that
survived being cut in half by a laser, and
having its neck snapped repeatedly over ten
hours by SCP-173.
So, while these two are gradually reconstituting
themselves…
again, why don’t we chalk this one up to
a tie?
“A tie?
Come on, man!
Hey, I’m still – wait for it, wait for
it – ‘a head’ of the competition!
Anyone?
Yeesh, rough crowd.”
Let’s just jump ahead a few hours, give
these two a chance to heal up.
Now, by this point our old pal Deadpool has
used most of his go-to options for a fight,
and they’re not exactly proving to be all
too effective against SCP-682.
“Hey, I’m doing my best here!”
The Hard to Destroy Reptile, on the other
hand, is still fresh for a fight, as extensively
healing itself rarely tires the creature out.
Combine that with a rage that just won’t
be quelled, and an opponent who isn’t just
another form of life, but another living being
who also can’t be killed without regenerating,
and that all adds up to one very angry lizard
and not a lot of other options for Deadpool.
“Other options, huh?
Okay, I can think of a few.”
With that, Deadpool vanishes.
Just like that, in the blink of an eye, he’s
gone.
It's not unprecedented for him, after all
he does possess a particular piece of technology
that allows him to do this.
Deadpool has been known to sometimes wear
a teleportation bracelet, a device created
by his friend and go-to for gadgets, Weasel.
As to exactly where he’s gone to, that’s
anyone’s guess.
It’s a bold strategy, just trying to outrun
SCP-682 instead of facing it, but admittedly
a little unexpected from…
“Ta-da, okay, I’m back!
And I brought new toys!”
In an astounding and completely baffling move,
Deadpool teleports right back to where he
was just standing.
Brandishing a golden glove with six shining
gemstones encrusted in it: the Infinity Gauntlet.
SCP-682 seems to know what this artefact is,
or is at least wary of it, and keeps its distance.
“Bet you weren’t expecting this, later
gator!”
Acting with a reckless abandon typical of
nobody other than him, Wade snaps his fingers.
Historically, only beings of immense power
are able to wield the Infinity Gauntlet and
survive.
The cosmically-powerful metal glove is designed
to combine the effects of the six Infinity
Gems, each one governing a different aspect
of existence – namely time, space, reality,
power, the mind and the soul.
As Deadpool’s fingers click, SCP-682 is
wiped from existence, turned into nothing
more than a pile of dust floating through
the air.
Unfortunately for Wade wielding it, the Gauntlet’s
cosmic energy is so uncontainable that it
is channelled back at him, almost obliterating
him entirely.
“Worth it, though.
Let’s see Brolin top that.”
To make matters worse, SCP-682 isn’t down
for long.
While Deadpool’s own healing factor is struggling
to restore him, the Hard to Destroy Reptile
is rapidly reconstituting itself, knitting
its physical form back into existence on a
cellular level, fueled by sheer hatred and
willpower.
Rummaging through the small collection of
objects he brought back with him when he returned,
Deadpool slips a metal helmet onto his head.
This is no ordinary helmet though, it’s
Cerebro, a powerful device used by Professor
Charles Xavier, a powerful psychic that uses
the helmet to amplify his powers and find
fellow mutants.
Although quite what Wade has planed for it
is anyone’s guess.
“Oh, well I’m glad you asked!
I’m technically brain dead, so I figured
I could use this doohickie to connect my mind
to the big nasty lizard over there.
Then, I can project my own brain death into
him and finally put an end to this wild ride.”
While it’s indeed an interesting plan, there
are unfortunately some pitfalls of Deadpool’s
latest tactic.
One being that only incredibly powerful psychics
like Professor X, Jean Grey, or Emma Frost
can even attempt to connect their mind to
Cerebro.
The other snare in the plan is, that’s not
how Cerebro works at all, it’s for tracking
mutants, not projecting someone’s consciousness
into the mind of another.
“Oh, come on, I’ve been fighting this
lizard, with you semi-sarcastically chastising,
me all afternoon.
Cut me a break here!
All I have left is this little whatchamacallit
that I stole from that stretchy Poindexter.”
With SCP-682 once again baring down on him,
Deadpool aimlessly fires the weapon.
Unbeknownst to him, the device he’s currently
holding is the Ultimate Nullifier, the most
devastating weapon in the entire universe.
The blast from the Nullifier envelops SCP-682,
completely and utterly eliminating it, violating
the very law of conservation of mass.
“Hey, what do you know, it worked!
Say, can I go now?
Wow, this thing is getting hot…
oh, look, a penny!”
One downside of using the Ultimate Nullifier
is that it can often backfire, completely
destroying the person wielding it too, especially
if their mind isn’t strong enough... or
if they lose focus.
And well, sadly Deadpool has a knack for getting
distracted.
While the Nullifier continues to obliterate
both its target, SCP-682, and its wielder,
Deadpool, its power destroys the entire universe
from beginning to end.
This power continues until it is the only
thing left in existence, only to then collapse
back on itself.
The Ultimate Nullifier ends up paradoxically
nullifying its own effect, ultimately then
recreating the universe in the blink of an
eye, including Deadpool and SCP-682.
So, we guess that’s another tie?
“Oh, come on!”
Now go and check out “SCP-096 VS SCP-173”
to see the outcome of another chaotic clash
between the Shy Guy and The Sculpture.
Or, for more tips on how to take down a certain
regenerating reptile, go and watch “WAS
SCP-682 REALLY THAT HARD TO KILL AFTER ALL?”